ah
tiens
tous les 6 juin en normandie souffle un
air de liberté de fraternité
on célèbre au rythme du rock'n roll le
débarquement de 1944
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des festivités pour honorer les vétérans
et se souvenir bien sûr
mais également pour faire venir le
touriste
[Musique]
car la plus grande opération militaire
de tous les temps fascine les foules
les plages mythiques de la région attire
5 millions de visiteurs par an
avec à la clé des milliers d'emplois
non
[Musique]
75 ans après le débarquement est donc
devenu une manne pour la normandie et le
tourisme de mémoire un pilier de son
économie
[Musique]
les fameuses plages du débarquement
les voici
omar hutasse ward dunod et gold
cinq noms qui ont fait le tour du monde
et ont changé le visage de la région
à quelques kilomètres du tas
sainte mère église 2600 habitants
ce n'est pas larchitecture du 12e siècle
convient photographié ici mais ce
mannequin accroché au clocher il
représente john style un parachutistes
largués le jour j est restée suspendue
jusqu'au matin du 6 juin 1944
sa mésaventure à changer le destin de la
commune elle est devenue le gagne pain
de stéphane marguerite le boulanger
facile à rouler
les touristes raffolent de ses baguettes
et croissants à la française mais
aujourd'hui ça ne suffit plus stéphane a
dû élargir sa gamme
ah ça c'est des burgers pour pour le
commerce d'à côté qui fait des
burgers des paninis il ya une très forte
demande de restauration rapide aussi et
puis les étrangers manger à toute heure
donc ils peuvent manger à 5 heures de
l'après midi
c'est un petit peu déroutant au début
mais quand tu fais quoi voilà on s'est
adapté à la demande quoi
mais surtout stéphane fait son beurre
avec une de ses créations
une gourmandise qui fait craquer les
huit cent mille touristes qui s'arrêtent
ici tous les ans
du beurre du sucre de la farine des
oeufs a priori rien d'extraordinaire en
fait tout est dans la forme on n'a pas
inventé des biscuits un nom qu'il
fallait trouver quelque chose d'original
à quelqu'un qui visuellement marre que
les gens avant de goûter un produit pour
l'acheter donc quand même que les gens
puissent l'identifier à sainte mère est
vraiment identifié par rapport à son
parachute qui assurent le clocher donc
c'est venu naturellement que on a pensé
à ce parachute quoi donc après c'est
comment le faire sous quelle forme reste
on aura pu le faire en forme de dessins
sur une galette ronde donc voilà en
cherchant un peu on
en faisant des essais on y tient ça se
voit ça pourrait être sympa
un biscuit en forme de parachute
personne n'y avait pensé jusque là
stéphane en vend en moyenne 7 milles par
jour c'est la recette du succès
voilà et les biscuits de sainte mère qui
sortent du four donc tout beau tout bon
et ça ça fait partie de notre produit
phare en 2010 on a commencé avec quatre
employés aujourd'hui on est 23 donc on a
pas que ce biscuit on a toute une gamme
aussi tout autour on a développé aussi
le chocolat il ya un restaurant aussi
derrière une boutique qui accueille le
public on est un peu d'épicerie fine
aussi donc voilà tout ce projet-là a
permis de créer des emplois
à deux euros cinquante le paquet un
souvenir bon marché pour les touristes
et finalement pour le boulanger un joli
parachute doré
[Musique]
le débarquement nourrit donc ici les
conversations et les habitants
les vitrines décline le thème d'ailleurs
à toutes les sauces
et les premiers à vouloir capter les
touristes ce sont les musées
dans l'air bornes muséum au coeur de
sainte mère on peut découvrir un
authentique planeur wako qui permit le
jour j d'acheminer hommes et matériel
derrière les lignes ennemies
ou encore ainsi 47 lui aussi d'origine
des pièces exceptionnelles sur lesquels
magali mallet la directrice veille
jalousement
[Musique]
ce musée a été créé en 1964 et depuis le
public a beaucoup changé
[Musique]
en 64 on n'avait pas vraiment besoin de
raconter ce qui s'était passé ici à nos
visiteurs ils le savaient pertinemment
puisqu'il l'avait vécue aujourd'hui un
jeune voilà il a vu un peu à l'école ce
qui s'est passé en dans la seconde
guerre mondiale et encore le focus est
plutôt mis sur la guerre totale sur la
shoah donc aujourd'hui c'est dans les
musées qu'on trouve qu'on trouve cette
histoire donc il faut qu'on soit du
pédagogique
et madame la directrice saisit toutes
les occasions pour rajeunir son
auditoire
ce jour là en fait ce sont les journées
du patrimoine
magali a invité une association de
passionnés qui font revivre un hôpital
américain le jour j une façon de créer
l'événement
certains visiteurs ont même fait des
dizaines de kilomètres pour ne pas
manquer ça
si l'histoire vivante et c'est un devoir
de mémoire aussi
très important pour apprendre aux jeunes
pour voir ce qui s'est passé comment
comment y procéder c'est important il
n'y a pas eu que la guerre au lit que
les soldats sur le terrain s'entretuer
donc là aussi mais la partie logistique
la partie médicale c'est aussi important
la reconstitution s'est donc une bonne
idée pour doper le nombre de visiteurs
mais les entrées ne sont pas la seule
source de revenus
la boutique est un endroit stratégique
[Musique]
ici il y a des centaines de références
et magalie est très fier de ça
c'est à dire une reproduction d'un cric
et
le criquet utilisé en 44 par les
parachutistes
comme signal de reconnaissance donc ça
c'est la vente numéro dans notre dans
notre boutique
clairement ça compromet 3 euros
vous achetez combien mois
après ce qui fonctionne c'est tout ce
qui est textile donc on va avoir du polo
du tee shirt
de la casquette grande vente également
une boutique c'est autour de 30 33 % du
chiffre d'affaires donc c'est important
effectivement oui oui tout à fait
le débarquement une opportunité en or
pour la normandie
et ça un homme l'a compris dès la fin du
conflit
raymond triboulet
ce résistant normand devenu député se
bat après guerre pour le souvenir de
cette page déterminante
[Musique]
avec une petite idée derrière la tête
jean quellien est historien spécialiste
de cette période au mois de mai 1945
raymond triboulet décide de mettre en
place le comité de débarquement dont le
but est extrêmement claires les statuts
explique qu'il s'agit de perpétuer la
mémoire et en même temps en même temps
d'organiser le tourisme dans cette
région donc d'emblée les deux termes
mémoire et tourisme sont liés dès 1945
d'ailleurs un grand nom du tourisme sans
le bon filon au même moment michelin
sort sa première carte sur cette
thématique alors que la france est
encore en ruines
[Musique]
et c'est à arromanches histoire et
tourisme commence vraiment à faire bon
ménage
[Musique]
il ne reste sur la plage que ces
caissons de béton
[Musique]
assemblés les uns aux autres ils ont
permis de créer un port artificiel pour
acheminer hommes et matériel
[Musique]
en 1954 pour rendre hommage à ce défi
technique
ouvre juste en face de la plage le
premier musée du débarquement
avec comme pièce maîtresse cette
maquette
[Musique]
indien de
la particularité de cette vitrine si
c'est qu'elle est animée avec un système
de came debbasch institude pour
reproduire les mouvements des marées
pour expliquer comment les ingénieurs
avaient mis au point un système qui
existe maintenant dans les marinas tout
simplement pour pouvoir décharger amar
et autres comme à marée basse avec un
système de plateforme monté sur quatre
pieux qui montait et descendait au gré
des marées
c'est l'âme du musée etc c'est la
maquette qui fait référence en termes de
en termes de port artificiel puisqu'elle
est unique il est unique au monde cette
maquette imaginé depuis 1954 nombre de
millions de personnes qu'elle a pu
accueillir et et servir de 2,2 pédagogie
vraiment au port artificiel qui était la
technique du port artificiel finalement
cette réplique est exceptionnelle mais
elle a l'âge du musée elle va donc
devoir battre en retraite pour laisser
la place aux nouvelles technologies
mc est une pièce unique de collection va
pas là on va pas là triture payante pas
de faire quelque chose de plus on va la
mettre un petit peu en arrière et on va
reconstruire une maquette
maquette 3d avec un petit peu de pour ne
rien cacher de là bien sûr la réalité
augmentée puisqu'il y a bien un jour où
ce malheureusement tout ça va
disparaître donc on doit trouver dès
aujourd'hui les moyens de faire perdurer
ce site même si cette version virtuelle
c'est en fait toute la muséographie
qu'il faut repenser pour rester au goût
du jour
car deux simples vitrines ne suffisent
plus à satisfaire la curiosité du public
[Musique]
quand vous voyez normes comme ça pose et
on a du mal à imaginer son
fonctionnement comment aller de l'autre
côté son poids et ainsi de suite donc
demain peut-être que cette âme ça sera
sur une borne tactile ne voit pas le
faire pivoter en 3d ou nora son poids sa
taille et instituts et explique pourquoi
pas son fonctionnement je pense que ça
c'est l'avenir
pour le pionnier des musées il ya même
urgence
car aujourd'hui la concurrence est rude
sur ce marché du débarquement
au fil des années les sites se sont
multipliées dans la région
on en compte désormais 94
surtout les institutions doivent faire
face à de nouveaux acteurs
car tout le monde peut ouvrir un musée
notamment les collectionneurs
[Musique]
ce matin-là un sainte mère église est
organisée une vente d'objets militaires
très tôt
ici tout le monde connaît emmanuel alain
un passionné toujours en quête de la
perle rare
emmanuel vivier en champagne il y a 20
ans il décide de déménager en normandie
pour être là où tout s'est passé
bon alors qu'est ce qui est beau aussi
mais qu'est ce qui est beau à pas cher
[Rires]
les fondus peuvent trouver de tout des
armes des casques des uniformes
jusqu'au nécessaire de toilette des
soldats
le tout pour quelques dizaines d'euros
avec parfois des exceptions comme se
cirer de motocyclistes allemand
mais cette fois ci la pêche pour
emmanuel n'est pas vraiment miraculeuse
plus durer
attachez vos ceintures
on sait combien ça
25 euros non
on était fous 25 euros à
l'aller 20
merci mais je vous en prie
ça permet de finaliser un mannequin donc
on a toujours besoin d'eux
deux choses pour finaliser un mannequin
des choses qu'on verra pas spécialement
parce qu'une fois que les équipements
qui sont autour on le voit pas bien mais
on n'a pas besoin que de pièces rares
non plus heureusement il ya ce qu'on
appelle un peu du courant et ça permet
d'acheter d'acheter des trucs à petit
prix
[Musique]
en trente ans de passion emmanuel s'est
constitué une grande collection qui
désormais le fait vivre
il la présente dans cette maison au
carrefour de lomme morts un lieu où
allemands et américains se livrèrent des
combats acharnés en juin 1944
alors ici on est dans la partie
historique du musée dans la maison
historique qui existaient à l'époque qui
a donc été utilisé par les parachutistes
allemands qui devait défendre 40 ans qui
est ensuite reprise par les
parachutistes américains qui eux
devaient prendre 40 ans donc c'est notre
propre collection ce ne sont que du
matériel original que nous exposons et
on est en quête de matériel et on essaie
d'enrichir cette propre collection au
fil des années pour pouvoir représenter
plus aux différents visiteurs donc là on
est encore dans la dans la partie musée
toujours dans la partie historique et
notamment voilà par exemple un objet qui
va enrichir de collection c'est le
ceinturon que j'ai acheté ce matin à la
bourse ça ça vous savez pour la partie
collection christophe avatar pour la
partie collection privée ça va aller sur
un mannequin quand un nouveau mannequin
qu'on va monter et ensuite on a eu notre
parti tout aussi important c'est le
magasin d'antiquités militaire ou là on
ne présente que du matériel original qui
datent de cette seconde guerre mondiale
et ici tout est à vendre pour le client
et pour le collectionneur ou le visiteur
lambda qui vous ramener une partie
d'histoire chez lui
un musée et un magasin d'antiquités
militaires
une façon de se démarquer des autres
sites de mémoire pour emmanuel
defer aussi de sa passion une bonne
affaire
car les originaux ça se paye
un des plus typiques ça va être bien
évidemment le criquet américains qui se
trouvent ici donc
le criquet souvenez vous la copie
coûtait 3 euros à la boutique de l'air
bande museum dès 1950 euros oui c'est
cher tout est relatif ça fait partie des
pièces très recherchés c'est l'objet le
plus mythique du débarquement de
normandie c'est très très recherchés il
y à une forte demande nous expédions
tous les jours dans le monde entier
aussi bien au brésil qu'en nouvelle
zélande il n'y a pas de limites de
frontières surtout maintenant avec
internet et aujourd'hui je pense qu'on
est un des rares musées a proposé ça à
nos visiteurs cette boutique aux
merveilles a fait d'emmanuel une
référence
alors forcément il a réponse à tout
c'est pour la radio célébrant l'antenne
pour l'année notamment pour le temps de
fou
vous montrez là directement
d'accord broken la radio l'antenne et en
os le cadran je vous ai vu démultiplié
tant de soin
bah voilà
ce jeune collectionneur vient ici pour
la première fois il a craqué pour ces
lettres de soldats allemands
je suis quelqu'un qui peut réellement
jaffré très je la ferai très dur ça
permettra de savoir c'est écrit dessus
elle a été écrit le 3 septembre 1942
elle a été tamponné ensuite
par la faible place allemande le 7
septembre
quatre jours après le 4ème temps renvoyé
après
n'y a pas forcément besoin de fortune et
après il ya les pièces qui vont être
très rarement très très cher mais après
5 euros on a un petit mort c'est
l'histoire d'un petit morceau d'histoire
chez soi
en misant sur l'authentic plutôt que sur
les produits dérivés
emmanuel a su se faire une place sous le
soleil normand
et pour ses clients féru d'histoire il
soigne tous les détails
ça c'est une machine d'époque pour faire
les plaques d'identité portés par les
soldats narnia c'est grave et emboutit
directement sur la plaque une fois de
plus on donne la possibilité aux
visiteurs de vous acheter une paire de
plaque porte une paire de claques comme
le faisaient les médias à l'époque
ça allait comme ça fait fureur
aujourd'hui les clients font graver des
informations personnelles et ça leur
coûte 20 euros les deux plaques terre
c'est que c'est d'ailleurs à bat yam
tous les autres ça va c'est cadeau
[Rires]
un geste pour le jeune homme qui vient
de dépenser une centaine d'euros dans la
boutique
[Applaudissements]
la petite affaire tourne bien mais
emmanuel voit encore plus grand
à l'arrière de la maison historique
il a fait construire ce hangar pour
faire vivre aux visiteurs l'histoire
autrement
[Musique]
et ça commence sur un ton très martiale
sauf
les
bastonnades shanxi
en hologramme le lieutenant vole vers
tonnes un personnage réel qui fut tuée
le jour j
dix minutes pour comprendre la mission
ensuite c'est l'embarquement dans un c
pouvait mettre en othe complet
donc là vous pouvez voir en fait elle se
retire voilà donc les gens ne voient pas
ça effectivement quand ils arrivent ici
elle pour eux l'avion est complet mais
nous pour faire bouger l'avion mais
obligé de faire retirer neil d'oncle
elle se retire afin de libérer toute la
partie fuselage qui elle va se mettre en
route pour donner les sensations
à l'intérieur des écrans remplacer les
hublots pour faire revivre aux touristes
cette fameuse nuit qui a changé le cours
de la guerre
c'est un véritable agent de 43 et donc
on l'a acheté haspilaire puisqu'il a
tourné dans la série frères d'armes ces
développeurs et band of brothers ça
reste véritable ses 47 d'époque qui a
véritablement servi au débarquement donc
voilà
cette expérience du jour j c'est 12
euros par personne et sept minutes de
turbulences
dans la réalité la traversée a duré deux
heures la peur au ventre pour les
parachutistes
auxerre pour rester dans la course
finale maintenant dans la course muséal
on va dire oui je sais pas s'il ya
vraiment une course mais il faut
dépoussiérer de toute façon les musées
et aujourd'hui nous je sais qu'on a fait
on a fait un sérieux bond et c'est
unique au monde on appelle ça une
attraction même si j'aime pas trop le
terme ça reste une attraction c'est
unique au monde et c'est vrai que les
gens apprécient aussi bien cette partie
là de la partie briefing avec
hologrammes qui est aussi de noter sur
le marché ce sera quoi la prochaine
étape c'est les gens vont se retrouver
sur la plage de normandie à se faire
tirer dessus non comme je dis toujours
pas ce qu'on me dit vous pourriez faire
si vous voyez faire ça mais bon on n'est
pas un parc d'attractions on est un
musée donc
il faut réessayer de le coter musées qui
aura une prochaine étape pour 2019 mais
ça sera pas des effets spéciaux
au moment d'arriver sur les côtes
françaises ce sont les tirs de la dca
allemande
touché le ses 47 fini par se crasher
[Musique]
une histoire qu'il finit bien pour les
touristes et pour emmanuel car cette
attraction a fait décoller son
entreprise
avant faisait entre quinze et vingt
mille entrées avec avec le petit
bâtiment au jeu cette année on a passé
la barre des 100000
[Rires]
au sol les positions sont claires le
territoire bien occupé entre musées et
passionné le marché commence à saturer
alors certains ont décidé de prendre un
peu de hauteur
[Musique]
on est prêts on demande la mise en route
personnellement
j'étais partement et retour pour les
installations
olivier boutet propose des vols en
hélicoptère au-dessus des plages du jour
j
il est l'un des tout premiers à s'être
mis sur ce créneau
[Musique]
à
chaque rotation et à 300 m d'altitude
cinq clients peuvent ainsi vivre
l'histoire avec vue imprenable
[Musique]
d ailleurs on hamm est différent les
listes en se rapprochant team
ya 50 ans chassé ces endroits comme les
bleus de portivy cielo si on ne va bien
qui je passe ici
j'adore
[Musique]
le cimetière américain de colleville et
c9 1385 sépulture
vu du ciel ils révèlent toute l'ampleur
de l'hécatombe
[Musique]
on dit rigueur les gens qui se sont
sacrifiés lors qui vécut même passé
mais pour ça pour la folie
avec eux avec le nazisme princesse
envoyez vos cages
[Musique]
chaque client doit débourser 200 euros
pour cette expérience hors norme le vol
dure 30 minutes
[Musique]
la seconde augmentation de
mairie bien venir se
recueillir réunion un petit peu les
enfants 10 e
[Musique]
coli
les touristes américains
[Musique]
des clients généralement aisée que tout
le monde s'arrache
ils constituent la moitié des étrangers
qui visitent la normandie aujourd'hui
[Musique]
et pour eux
1984 qui célèbre le 40e anniversaire du
débarquement reste une date marquante
[Applaudissements]
cette année là ronald reagan fait le
déplacement afin de rendre hommage aux
soldats tombés ici pointe du hoc
cette visite présidentielle marquent un
tournant
elle va raviver l'intérêt des américains
pour les plages normandes
et la pointe du roc devient même un lieu
de pèlerinage
ces visiteurs d'outre-atlantique font
des heureux
les guides
150 travail sur ce marché
regardez c'est l'un des 12 milles bunker
que les allemands ont construit parmi
eux romain 10 ans d'expérience
viennent chercher beaucoup de choses
pour certains pas très souvent et pour
certains ça va être tourné là où leurs
grands parents ou leurs grands oncles
ont combattu pour beaucoup ils veulent
voir pour de vrai ce qui s'est passé et
quand ils arrivent ici ils voient enfin
les vrais bunker allemand ça apporte
quelque chose de beaucoup plus vivant
ils savent que une fois qu'ils vont être
sur place sur tout ce qu'ils ont un
guide toutes les questions qui se
posaient qu'ils n'avaient pas compris le
guide va être capable de leur donner
quelque chose d'une explication qui va
enfin faire un sens donc dans leur
esprit ok d'habitude les américains
débarquent en nombre et en bus
là nous allons sur la vraie plage
d'omaha beach
et nous allons prendre le temps
d'expliquer ce qui s'est vraiment passé
le 6 juin 44
mais romain propose un service en petit
comité et à la carte
ils sont huit donc c'est quasiment à
tour privé
c'est vraiment pas un service de taxi on
n'est pas là pour a simplement arriver
leur dire voilà ça c'est la pointe du
hoc on se retrouve dans une demi heure
c'est le concept de la visite à la carte
de temps en temps sur un tour où on est
censé aller sur simplement sur trois
endroits quand les gens vont me dire ah
bah tiens moi mon oui moi mon grand père
il a il était il faisait partie de génie
il a débarqué sur omaha à telle heure on
va leur dire vous savez quoi c'est pas
prévu vraiment dans tour mais on va
s'arrêter à cet endroit là sur la plage
omaha beach
au mas la sanglante la plage la plus
célèbre du débarquement
les américains veulent toujours s'y
arrêter
car cette plage il la voit dans tous les
films de guerre hollywoodiens
et
[Musique]
il faut sauver le soldat ryan band of
brothers ou encore le jour le plus long
des succès au box office qui joue sur le
registre de l'émotion
romain lui au contraire prend le temps
de rétablir quelques vérités de
décrypter les tactiques
tekken 6 vous orienter les canons face à
la mer vous ne défendez qu'une portion
de la plage si vous les orientez sur le
côté vous couvrez toute sa longueur
de bitche on n'est pas là pour leur dire
simplement on va vous vendre le jeu
vidéo on va vous vendre le soldat ryan
voilà c'est ça s'est passé tom hanks il
a débarqué là non on est là pour leur
dire voilà ça c'est ce que l'industrie
de loisirs va vous montrer mais la
réalité elle est beaucoup plus compliqué
que ça quand on leur dit qu'ils à vingt
mille civils dans la bataille normandie
qui ont été tués majoritairement
malheureusement par les bombes alliées
c'est quelque chose qu'il découvre
et pour certains même l'idée de la
normandie c'est pas clair la normandie
c'est une classe avec peut-être sept
kilomètres de plages et les américains
les britanniques et les canadiens
débarque sur 7 km de plage et la plage
et s'appelle normandie
c'est ce que je croyais qu'il n'y avait
qu'une plage c'est que chaque mois c'est
une partie différente de la plage je ne
pensais pas qu'elle était aussi loigné
les unes des autres on l'a compris en
venant ici
ce tourisme de la mémoire se termine au
cimetière de colleville
un passage obligé pour tous les
américains
en normandie ce site est le plus visité
après le mont saint michel et romain
s'arrange toujours pour y arriver à la
descente des couleurs
[Musique]
nous avons appris plein de choses sur
les aspects militaires et l'organisation
du débarquement
c'est une histoire fascinante sans
oublier le sacrifice de toi season
[Musique]
je recommande ce voyage c'est une
expérience qui n'a pas de prix
[Musique]
l'enjeu pour l'économie locale c'est de
faire rester quelques jours c'est
touristes venus de l'autre bout du monde
et pour cela il faut les héberger et les
choyer
françois hébert n'est ni collectionneurs
ni directeur de musée lui est hôteliers
et il sillonne la région à l'affût des
meilleurs produits locaux pour ses
visiteurs américains alors on arrive au
château beau et charmant petit château
familial on y fait du très bon c'est
dans les très bons calva à l'histoire
françois ajoute donc le savoir-faire
normand
conquérir les clients flattant leur
palais voilà une de ces stratégies
et cette fois ci il va goûter un
assemblage de très vieux calvin
coûtait
déjà le petit 1 c'est sympathique
il ya de la pomme
rodage
à ta santé avec délicatesse
on tourne un peu autour
hélas le mieux maintenant tu gardes en
bouche sans la vallée et tue le match
dégage tout resserrement dans ta bouche
en fait le calvados est un alcool que
les américains ont découvert avec le
débarquement le djihad qui débarque
c'est découvre le coup de cidre que les
fermiers lui lui offre et puis
une fois qu'il a bu le site bah tiens
mon gars qui va voir un petit verre de
calva et pour eux c'est quelque chose
c'est une découverte donc pour eux c'est
très très emblématique le calvados et
probablement avec le camembert ski le
ski le plus emblématique
de la normandie
et c'est que l'on peut également mettre
dans sa valise
il faut éviter que les touristes ne
reste qu'une seule journée alors
françois a tout prévu
il a installé son hôtel ici au coeur de
bayeux connu pour sa cathédrale et sa
tapisserie
sa stratégie commerciale et claire misé
sur le confort pour gagner la clientèle
américaine aisée
et pendant que monsieur fait les courses
c'est madame qui reçoit
dans un anglais absolument parfait
nous on cible les américains parce que
c'est un public qui vient beaucoup
visiter les plages du débarquement et il
manquait un marché un peu luxueux dans
le coin pour accueillir ces gens et du
moment où on s'occupe d'eux et on prend
soin d'eux ils sont ravis ils sont
heureux tout ce passe bien ils sont en
vacances et le français il laisse guider
la ccar tu sais où aller a émis si on me
dit est ce que vous avez bien dormi
cette nuit il va nous dire pourquoi vous
me posez la question quoi alors qu'un
américain si on les pose pas des
questions il va pas comprendre qu'on
s'inquiète pas de comment c'est passé sa
nuit
mais ce service à un prix
entre 300 et 600 euros la nuit c'est
notre suite en fonction du standing de
la chambre
donc une autre salle de bain avec une
grande ouche la chambre avec un lit king
size
c'est une chambre standard américain
parce que les américains cherchent de
l'espace donc toutes nos chambres faut
au minimum 30 mètres carrés
mais restait très sur le made in france
on optait plutôt pour une couverture que
pour une couette parce qu'on voulait
annie fait à la française c'est ben ali
elle apprend à la france s est un libyen
bordés
avoir une couette qui justement avoir un
bon quart et enfin de lier avec une
belle couverture donc on a choisi des
couvertures en alpaga et les clients
raffolent d'ailleurs de ses couvertures
là puisqu'on les ventes en boutique ils
leur achètent aussi
quelques centaines d'euros la couverture
tout de même il y a donc une boutique
pour rapporter les draps de l'hôtel à la
maison en plus des produits régionaux
et tout cela c'est bien sûr grimper la
note
ce subtil mélange de classicisme
français de confort à l'américaine se
retrouve aussi dans les salons et le
lobby
[Musique]
j'espère vous revoir prochainement et je
vous enverrai un courrier merci c'est
gentil reese
donc fort bien il sera d'ouvrir la porte
c'est bien gbagbo c'est parti pour un
tour ok
c'est super
françois surf aussi sur cette mode du
tourisme de mémoire
c'est le meilleur moment de la journée
pour profiter un peu du soleil nous
avons juste un petit morceau de ciel
bleu entre les nuages au bon client il
offre un extra une virée dans sa jeep
willys
c'est la voiture de la liberté de la
libération c'est une voiture qui parle
qui a une histoire et qui parle
bien évidemment un aux touristes à nos
clients étrangers qui viennent visiter
les plages du débarquement et c'est vrai
que
elle attire tout de suite les regards
les gens aiment bien monter dedans posé
pour la photo devant et c'est ma force
c'est la première fois de jouer dans une
ville comme ça de 1944
c'est super on n'a pas ce genre de jeep
chez nous et s'il y en a elles sont dans
les musées et de toute façon c'est
interdit de rouler avec ce genre de
véhicules aux états unis
c'est beau quand les bombes se
rejoignent et formule 1
matthew son passager est originaire de
pennsylvanie
c'est la première fois qu'il vient en
normandie il a passé toute sa journée
sur les sites de mémoire mais en
redemande encore
alors françois s'improvise guide
c'est difficile d'imaginer comment
c'était le 6 juin 44
si vous êtes à l'intérieur
moi je n'aurais pas aimé être là ce jour
la main
[Musique]
voici la batterie de longues-sur-mer
souvent délaissé par les grands tours
opérators
on peut y voir les derniers bunkers
allemand encore équipés de leurs canons
d'origine
qu'avec les copains rouge et vous
défendre contre des navires de guerre il
faut bien des canons comme ça ouais
c'est vraiment magnifique et bien
conservé une belle page d'histoire bien
sauvegarder et en point d'orgue
françois n'oublie jamais de célébrer la
paix
et les libérateurs
c'est vraiment un privilège de boire du
vin ici sur une jeep américaine de la
seconde guerre mondiale
sacrée expérience
à l'amitié entre la france et l'amérique
françois le sexe un client satisfait est
un client qui revient
[Musique]
des musées des boutiques des
reconstitutions le tourisme de mémoire
peut donc rapporter gros
l'offre est pléthorique sur ce marché
mais le risque c'est que le visiteur s'y
perdent
alors
donc la mise en page pour l'édition 2018
dominique sausset et charger de tous
répertoriés
elle est employée par la région et édite
depuis trois ans ce petit guide la bible
pour les sites de mémoire
[Musique]
ce jour là elle a rendez vous avec son
graphiste pour préparer la prochaine
édition
en fait
je vais peut-être te demandé de
retravailler sur une carte pour la
version allemande en fait ok un logo
déposé depuis quelques années le
débarquement est devenu une marque
commerciale
pour que les gens puissent nous repérer
il fallait qu'on ait fait qu'on est une
marque pour tout de suite ça face à oui
c'est c'est la normandie c'est la
destination d'excellence sur la seconde
guerre mondiale et sur la bataille le
jour de bottes du débarquement et la
bataille de normandie donc ça permet de
voilà en un clin d'oeil que les gens
repères et comprennent où on est
content le marketing entre donc dans
l'histoire
[Musique]
et pour son guide dominique ne veut
laisser personne de côté
[Musique]
car certains sites sont un peu les
oubliés du débarquement
le mémorial de montormel est à 60
kilomètres des plages seulement mais
cette distance le mette à l'écart de la
vague touristique
dominique s'y rend une fois par an pour
en faire l'évaluation
[Musique]
et ça commence par une visite et
d'atteinte et à des projets pour cette
partie va l'utiliser on est en train de
se demander si les photos faut pas les
déplacer les mettre ailleurs et puis
réserver uniquement la pièce et la zone
ici pour l'explication avec le public du
champ de bataille tout à fait vrai ici c
est sans doute passé la plus grande
bataille qu'ils aient lieu à l'ouest de
l'europe pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale vous avez cent cinquante mille
alliés grosso modo qui vont en cercle et
sans mines allemand les allemands
perdent dix mille hommes dix mille tués
en 48 prisonniers il y en a 50 % de
l'effectif cinq ans pauline qui
réussissent à sortir vous avez les
français de la 2e db les américains sur
la ligne de crête à l'horizon les
troupes britanniques
les canadiens et les polonais qui
viennent se placer ici comme un bouchon
cette plaine baptisé le couloir de la
mort n'accueille que onze mille
visiteurs chaque année
c'est trente fois moins que le musée
d'arromanches
cette bataille-là est passée totalement
inaperçue lorsqu'elle est coincé entre
le 15 août débarquement en provence et
25 août la libération de paris qui ont
écrasé les événements ici
figurer en bonne place sur le guide de
dominique c'est l'espoir d'entrer plus
nombreuses
deuxième étape de l'évaluation le
questionnaire ricains oui à tuer un
système de réservation sur ton site
internet m'en tape là qu'est tout un
dépliant sont traduits en anglais willy
mixte france l'ong est d'accord ce que
tu fais des audioguides oui alors les
chiffres de l'année 2016
donc l'année dernière on a clôturé
l'année 11590
ok ça c'est une grecque on a mis en
place
en 2014 il fallait qu'on puisse
répertorier tous les musées payant et
leur donner une sorte heures pas de
hiérarchie parce que je n'aime pas ce
terme mais plutôt montrer quels étaient
les sites incontournables et ceux qui
étaient complémentaires et que ça permet
de se situer par rapport aux autres
sites d'avoir un élément de comparaison
par rapport aussi de la côte sur tout
ici on a un petit peu excentré donc
comme ça on voit qualitativement à quel
niveau où on est par rapport aux autres
sites donc tu as hautmont déjà 71 sur
100 et il me faut encore des éléments
par rapport à la visite du site internet
le nombre de visiteurs uniques donc ce
qui donc est un bon point est donc ce
qui permet de confirmer que tu auras une
page sur le guide n'a l'idée parce que
tu as pu tuer un site incontournable ok
voilà bien donc félicitations quand au
plus tôt ben oui ils à avoir une pleine
page non mais guy commune du temps sur
le sur le petit livret qui soyons clairs
et très intéressant il faut se mettre à
la place du touriste lambda qui arrive
en normandie il d'un seul coup il a tout
le panorama des sites qui peuvent venir
voir être présent sur une pleine page
bien sûr c'est se garantir un minimum de
gens qui vont venir donc oui c'est
important
le guide de dominique ne sert pas qu'aux
visiteurs particuliers
nous sommes à paris porte de versailles
une fois par an les professionnels du
tourisme se retrouvent ici pour
concevoir vos prochaines vacances
au milieu des grandes destinations et
des têtes d'affiché le jour j est devenu
une vitrine de la normandie tout autant
que le mont saint michel
et dominique à quelques jours pour
convaincre les clients du monde entier
de venir voir cette terre chargée
d'histoire
[Musique]
vous avez sinon le guide des mystères
des plages débarquement là c'est
vraiment la thématique d'idées donc ça
c'est mon travail
donc l'annoncé l'édition de mai 17 ans
et
pour en mars avril vous pourrez recevoir
l'édition 2018 si vous voulez qu'on a
des clientèles scolaires la sint c'est
une professionnelle scolaire on a des
clientèles on va certainement avoir des
clientèles pour les sites pour les
touristes américains parisien français
belges après on a aussi les nouveaux
marchés maintenant l'amérique du sud
l'asie fin voilà on essaie aussi
de toucher de nouvelles de nouveaux
marchés en fait qui qui sont encore très
faibles sur les sites de mémoire il faut
être présent il faut être visible
l'objectif c'est de faire du business en
fait
un business qui dans quelques mois
pourrait bien connaître un nouvel essor
de se tendre
quelques jours plus tard sur juno beach
tous les acteurs de ce tourisme de
mémoire se sont donné rendez vous
les élus les directeur du musée les
passionnés
leur but faire inscrire les plages du
débarquement au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco
évidemment emmanuel alain le
collectionneur se devait d'être là
c'est important pour la région normandie
justement de mener à terme ce projet on
sait que à un endroit classé au
patrimoine de l'unesco s'est plus ou
moins 25 à 30 % d'augmentation au niveau
de la fréquentation
c'était un peu bizarre de parler
économie quand on est sur une plage ou
des avons souffert
non faut pas se voiler la face je pense
que pour la région normandie c'est très
très important il y aura forcément des
retombées économiques mais l'un ne va
pas sans l'autre c'est très important au
niveau de l'histoire parce que quand on
fêtera le centième anniversaire nous
malheureusement on sera plus là mais les
générations futures elles seront bien
présentes et faut pas qu'ils oublient
mais évidemment il ya un côté retombées
économiques bien évidemment
si cette reconnaissance mondiale se
confirme
le business du débarquement aura donc de
très beaux jours devant lui
[Musique]